invité de ce journal quelques douglas
scop douglas bonsoir date ou encore vous
présentez vous êtes l'un des acteurs
avec qui elle est reconnue dans le monde
vous avez tourné en tout dans une
centaine de films avec des réalisateurs
prestigieux comme kubrick minnelli
preminger ou de palma mais c'est pour un
livre que vous nous vous invitons ce
soit votre deuxième livre est votre
premier roman la danse du diable édité
par olivier orban alors kirk douglas
écrivain parce que ça veut dire que vous
allez abandonner le cinéma
rassurez moi vous savez j'ai pensé que
je vais abandonner le cinéma parce que
ça me mettrait beaucoup d'écrits un
livre mais j'ai reçu un sonar de la part
des deux abbés costa et donc quatre
jours je vais commencer en forme
en français cela me permet ce que je
n'ai pas oublié comme claquement que je
suis un acteur alors vous avez écrit un
roman c'est votre premier roman est ce
que la rencontre avec l'écriture d'un
roman a été difficile pour vous vous
savez quand j'ai écrit mes mémoires
d'abord j'ai commencé la danse des
arbres j'ai des croisés de 8 ans et dans
le milieu j'ai décidé d'écrire les
mémoires
et après ça j'ai filé dans ce diable
ménages est en train de et que autrement
après le film que je suis en train de
faire à nouveau à rome
il est très occupé votera pas je suis
jeune j'ai beaucoup de fourrure se doit
tout ça tu dois travailler chez un jeune
femme sait ce que c'est important
ce roman que vous venez d'écrire la
danse du diable c'est un véritable cri
de colère contre quelque chose que vous
détestez qui est le mensonge
oui vous savez je crois qu'on doit est
le mensonge qu'on dit ah ah vous même ce
pieux et émergents qui se crashe
qu'est ce qu'il a et moi c'est à cause
de ça la cause est celui de congé est en
train de l'écrire que j'ai écrit mes
mémoires
j'ai pensé qu'on doit prendre l'un 23
victoires en 10 à la 23éme l'inventaire
bas ventre
toujours pour savoir où j'étais où je
suis et où ira je crois que ça c'est le
thème de la danse de diable ça vous a
donc fait réfléchir sur vous même
exactement
alors rassurez nous vous avez dit vous
avez beaucoup de projets aussi bien dans
le cinéma que dans l'écriture
vous allez tourner en france est-ce que
vous pouvez nous dire quelques mots sur
le film que vous allez tourner vous
savez j'ai fait chaud mais cela arrive
donc j'ai dit que deux îles castanet je
vais les jouer avec richard bohringer et
c'est un film qui mènerait beaucoup
parce que c'est un sujet mais j'ai jou
quelconque et le projet de nature ou
protéger la nature
c'est quelque chose très peu de sens
pour moi j'aimais beaucoup de le faire
carl douglas je vous remercie beaucoup
d'avoir participé à ce journal
je rappelle le titre de votre livre la
danse du diable un roman édité chez
olivier orban
voilà ce journal sa chef